Iván cupca alcalde de nijurisca evalúa
con franqueza la situación en la zona
Julio malísima la situación es mala
Este es el río inhuluez que en este
punto suele tener 80 metros de ancho y
está atravesado por dos puentes hoy
cután necesita una lancha rápida para
llegar a las comunidades repentinamente
aisladas de la otra orilla allí la
espera lleven el líder de la aldea
llevo dos días suplicando a la gente que
evacue pero me dicen que no que no voy a
salir de mi casa que prefiero subirme al
tejado que no quieren ir a ninguna parte
a pesar de que sus casas ya están bajo
el agua
es la abuela la que no quiere irse
intentamos convencerla pero no quiere
mi marido y yo trabajamos mucho tenemos
tres vacas y un toro y dos terreneros
trabajamos mucho por los niños
levantarse y dejarlo atrás no sé es duro
para el alma
incapaces de persuadir a las víctimas de
las inundaciones para que se vayan
preguntan qué pueden traer cuántos niños
pequeños hay aquí que necesitan comida
para bebés actualmente No hay ninguna
carretera accesible para salir de estos
pueblos cuyo sea residentes ya
soportaron meses de ocupación rusa y
bombardeos queremos dirigirnos al mundo
entero buena gente mira lo que está
pasando
fue nombrado jefe de la Administración
militar cuando se liberó la zona en
noviembre
no pensé que el agua fuera a llegar tan
alto todos los pozos están inundados con
esa agua inutilizables
se ha descubierto que las aguas de la
inundación contienen varias toxinas en
cantidades peligrosas
hay escasez de agua porque todos
nuestros pozos están en la llanura
fluvial de la cuenca del Río y nulettes
y están inundados
las cosas podrían empeorar aún más una
de las muchas tareas urgentes de cupta
es asegurarse de que el agua sucia no
contamina una importante estación de
bombeo cercana que abastece a cientos de
miles de personas en Nicolás y gerson